i don't know true's getting older and i
just feel like it's now
time to have another kid
yup i like to hear
khloe kardashian and tristan thompson
are getting serious about baby number
two
and now a source is opening up to e.t
that coco wants to get married it would
be amazing
in november the 29 year old nba star
signed with the boston
celtics and a source tells et that
despite
the distance he and the 36 year old
reality star are
stronger than ever and in constant
communication
while she stays in la with their
two-year-old daughter true
quote tristan and chloe spend a lot of
time on the phone while he's in boston
face timing texting talking and chloe
has tried to visit whenever she has the
time to
the source adds that they send each
other a lot of gifts when they are apart
like flowers and balloons and when they
are together they like to have nice
meals and spend time outside
i'm really just enjoying my life of
course tristan and chloe rekindled their
romance in august
after more than a year apart the athlete
was previously involved in multiple
cheating scandals
including one with kylie jenner's former
bestie jordan woods
in 2019. you know things happen and of
course
i'm sorry and apologetic as much as i
can be but e.t source says
coco has let it go quote chloe forgives
tristan at this point but she will never
forget
they are back to being committed are
still in love and
giving their relationship another chance
and hoping that it will succeed
this time around tristan has been paying
extra attention to chloe and true
and checks in on them all the time when
they are not physically together
i'm just super happy and content oh and
the source also says that having more
kids together is still very much
in the cards explaining that it's
definitely been a conversation
and coco has been adamant about wanting
a big family
and when it comes to tying the knot she
of course sees herself
marrying tristan one day but he has a
lot to prove in order for their
relationship to elevate to that level
and on the 20th and final season of
keeping up with the kardashians
fans will get to see the good american
founder tell her man she's
ready for baby number two in my head
when i was gonna have kids i
never ever imagined having an only child
and especially being on
quarantine with her i felt bad like she
had no friends she had nobody and it was
because
you know they were isolated even from
each other for so long
i don't know true's getting older and i
just feel like it's now
time to have another kid
yup i like to hear
yeah tristan he's like super duper down
chloe explains that she's already frozen
her eggs
and now she's ready to start the process
of giving true
a sibling okay i think i'm ready to do
the whole pregnancy thing again this
process might take time i have no idea
so
i just think start the process at least
be prepared i think it's gonna work i
think it's gonna work exactly
you know i've always wanted like four
kids so i have prince and true
two down two more to go okay well we'll
just have to see what
what happens we'll just have to tune in
to see what happens on the final season
of keeping up with the kardashians when
it premieres
march 18th on e
[Music]